- Thank you, everybody, for joining us
in this week two of 10 questions.
This evening's question is
what
(audience laughs)
is
time?
One of our world's greatest photographers
and a colleague here at UCLA, Kathy Opie,
has said it this way, ideas always start
with questions.
Questions powerfully drive
research of all kinds today.
It drives forward whether in the sciences,
the humanities, in medicine or the arts
and arts indeed and part of
the predicate of this course
is that the arts are a form of research,
they're research into ideas
and things that not only shape
but become our world and
if you'd allow me to take
a few minutes here, I'd
like to briefly introduce
to all of you 10 questions
and then introduce each
of our terrific guests
here with us this evening
so I am Brett Steele,
the host of this event
here and dean of the UCLA
School of the Arts and Architecture
and you are joining us here at the school
for a very special experiment in education
and public programming,
10 questions is both
a lecture course with
80 students, students,
give me a shout out, where are you,
so we can see you here.
With students and this is a public event.
Public, a show of hands and thank you
so much for coming in,
this combination of class
and public event gives us an
opportunity to build bridges.
To build bridges rather
than reinforce walls
between the university and
the public whom we serve.
We are striving here to
make a state of the art
education not only more
visible but literally
more available in the world around us,
in turn, by making UCLA more porous,
we hope to communicate
to you, our students,
the importance of the
work each of you are doing
in the classroom and beyond,
each of the questions
being asked in this series
is drawn from the critical engagement
of arts practitioners, who
we canvassed considerably
for many months to come up
with the list of 10 questions
that have organized this
course, the questions of space,
time, beauty, freedom,
memory, the body, failure,
work and knowledge are all
central to artistic practices
of all kinds today, by
sharing these inquiries
with not only artists but
also scientists, scholars
and activists, we genuinely
believe that we are building
a stronger foundation for
understanding both disciplinary
commonalities and different
individuated perspectives.
In this way we hope to
both build and develop
an appreciation for the interdisciplinary,
the interdisciplinarity
that is so necessary
for progress in this tightly
interconnected 21st century
universe that you all know so well.
Over these 10 weeks, 10
questions will bring together
40 terrific faculty
members across the entire
UCLA campus, students
enrolled in this course
include majors from the School
of the Arts and Architecture
as well as neuroscience,
biology, French, music,
political science and many,
many other campus majors.
In addition to being
here Tuesday evenings,
you students meet weekly
with our graduate teaching
assistants in the course,
Kyle, Jing Jing, Anna
and Haley, who are here
with us this evening
to respond to and discuss these questions,
creating as well as curating
your own individuated
responses in a variety
of different formats.
10 questions is the
brainchild of Victoria Marks,
choreographer and associate dean
in the School of Arts and Architecture.
Victoria is right here up front everybody.
(audience applauds)
Nurturing and bringing
this project to fruition
with Victoria and to the broader public
is the work of Anne Marie
Burke sitting next to Victoria,
right up here up front.
(audience applauds)
Our school's executive
director of communications
and public relations as well as her team,
Kyle Kerrigan and Louise Kale.
Jennifer Wells Green, our
executive director of development
worked alongside Victoria
and Anne Marie to ensure
that Friends of UCLA
were able to join in this
unique project, finally,
Marilyn Pace offered
her tremendous expertise
in UCLA teaching to ensure
that this moved forward
in the form that it is,
so thank you to all who've
made that possible here
within the school and I know
like in any introduction,
time is of the essence, but
please, two more thanks here,
very briefly, alongside
Victoria and Anne Marie,
I wish to thank two vice
provosts here at UCLA
for supporting our initiative, Tim Brewer,
our Vice Provost for
Interdisciplinary and Cross Campus
Affairs, provided a seed
grant initially to allow us
to plan this work, and Roger Wakamoto,
our Vice Provost for Research
provided additional support
which when combined with our own efforts,
has been able to make this event possible
and more accessible, and finally we thank
the Department of World Arts Culture Dance
for their enormous support,
for this terrific venue
and for the considerable
technical expertise
which is spread around
the room as I'm speaking
that makes an event like this possible.
And with that as a broad introduction,
I'd like to briefly
introduce each of our guests
here this evening, Professor
Rebecca Mendez here on my left
joins us from the Department
of Design Media Arts.
Rebecca is an artist and designer who uses
a variety of media to explore
the nature of perception
in media representation,
she is especially interested
in how cultures express
themselves through the style
of nature that they
produce at any given time
and the medium through which
they construct this idea
of nature.
James Newton, professor,
distinguished professor,
James Newton joins us from
the Herb Albert School
of Music, and is the
Department of Ethnomusicology.
(audience applauds)
James is one of the world's
true flute virtuosos
in numerous musical idioms,
his work encompasses chamber,
symphonic and electronic
music genres, compositions
for ballet and modern
dance and numerous jazz
and world music contexts.
Associate professor Asma Sayeed,
joins us from the college's
Department of Near Eastern
Languages and Cultures, Asma
is the program director.
(audience applauds)
Is the program director
of Islamic Studies.
Her primary research interests
are in early and classical
Muslim social history, the
history of Muslim Education,
the intersections of
law and social history
and women and gender studies.
And finally, UCLA executive
vice chancellor and provost
Scott Waugh.
(audience applauds)
Is a scholar of medieval
history who for the past decade
has served as the chief
operating and academic officer
here at UCLA, Scott
guides strategic planning,
policy development, and campus
wide academic initiatives.
He has previously served
as the Dean of the Division
of Social Sciences and
the College of the Letters
and Sciences where he holds
a professorial appointment
in the Department of History
and where he will be returning
full time at the end of
this academic year to focus
on his scholarly research, so thank you,
the four of you, for
coming in this evening.
(audience applauds)
For all of you for coming,
we will follow a format
as we did last week in
which each of our guests
will give a brief presentation,
I will open up the floor
to a discussion between
our guests this evening.
You all will be invited
to join in this session
and I'm sure it'll be a terrific
one, thank you, everybody.
(audience applauds)
And our first presentation
this evening is Scott Waugh.
(audience laughs)
- Oh, rats, okay, thank you
very much for that introduction,
overly generous, good evening everyone,
it's a pleasure to be here
and pleasure to see you all.
I'm going to talk about how
historians look at time,
historians of modern Europe
or European historians,
this'll give us two different perspectives
on how historians look at time,
I'm gonna focus really on
three issues that European
historians have looked at
in a broad range of European history.
The first is the technology
of time and that's the
transition from bells to
clocks to watches and so on
which has a long history in
the west and all over the world
and that's one thing that people look at
and we'll see how that
comes back at the end.
The second is sort of the
metaphysical notion of history.
With the decline of the
Roman Empire and the rise
of Christianity,
Christian conceptions of
time kind of took over
in the medieval west and
dominated western thought
for a long, long time, the
easiest way of seeing that
is in the Bible as history,
there's an Old Testament
and a New Testament, divided
by the coming of Christ
and then with the prefiguring of the
last judgment.
That also opens up the
notion of a temporal
versus the eternal, which was
as much on people's minds,
the temporal, the post, after the fall,
after Adam and Eve, men
and women were subject
to all the vicissitudes of
life and subject to time.
Whereas the eternal which
was the realm of God
was without time or could be conceived of
as endless time, time
after time after time.
And the notion was of
course, the common notion was
that that temporal age would
end at the last judgment,
everything would be brought
together and some people
would enjoy eternity, either
up above us or below us
in heaven or in hell and that
was a kind of dominant theme.
Another aspect of that
that was very important
was that the teleological
aspect, people thought
of history as having an end,
it was guided towards something,
things were either going to get better
or they were going to get
worse, but they were always
going to an end and that
end was the end of time
so the Christian conception
of time in the medieval West
was very dominant and had
really captured people's minds.
It also captured people's
minds in another way,
which I'll come back to,
and then finally the third
conception is a social
and economic conception of
time, how society patterns time
or the vice versa, how time
patterns social activities
and work, and those were two
very, very important issues
and they are the issues
that really surround
what became one of the
central and has been
one of the central concerns
of European history
for a long time and that is modernization
or industrialization, now modernization,
industrialization, is a process
that lasted for centuries
in Europe, it is a process
that is still going on
around the world, you can
think of it in simple terms
as industry, factories,
trade, globalization,
but more importantly from our standpoint
here in this group, it also requires
a radical restructuring
of time, of movement
from preindustrial to
post industrial time.
And those are two radically
different regimes.
In order to show you how
radically different they were
in the European west, I'll
refocus on, to begin with,
preindustrial time, agrarian
time, the time dominated
by the work of the fields, the work that
the majority, the vast
majority, 99, 95, 99%
of the population enjoyed or
worked in during their lives
so it's that early aspect
that I want to think about
and when you think about agrarian time,
you have to think about
day time because night
was absolutely dark and the possibility
of falling into a cesspool,
stepping on a plow,
getting rolled over by a
cart was all too common
so you didn't go out after
dark, you were too poor,
likely, to have candles even,
so most of the European West
was really dark, so we're
talking about daytime
and daytime was structured by work.
The way in which you organized your day,
the way in which you
thought about your day
was according to the tasks you did.
Now how many of you are horse racing fans?
Okay, how long is a furlong?
You don't know?
Eighth of a mile, well,
that's almost correct,
it's the distance that
a plow team could go
in a straight line before
it had to turn around
and come back again to
plow the other side.
That's where, it's a furrow long.
Now.
Given that, and given that
several furrows make an acre,
how big is an acre?
Oh, God, you're so post industrial.
(audience laughs)
An acre is the amount
of land that a plow team
could plow in one day.
Okay?
Now that's somewhat irregular
if you think about it.
If you plow in heavy
clay soil, you're only
gonna be able to plow a little bit.
If you're plowing in light sandy soils,
you're gonna plow a lot,
so an acre which is a day's
worth of work for a plow
team, varied from one place
to another, that irregularity
is what characterizes
preindustrial time or preindustrial work.
It's not divided by time,
it's divided by the tasks
you have to do.
And there's no real division
between life and leisure,
work and things that you need to do,
it's irregular and that
kind of irregularity
dominates the way in which people live.
Villages were organized around churches,
the church bell rang, the morning rang,
the evening rang when
you had to go to Mass,
didn't tell time, didn't
have any timekeeping as such.
You had the sun, you had
the cock crow and you had
basically your work and that was the way
in which the rhythms of life were set.
Sunrise, sunset, and the various
seasons that went with it.
The calendar, the annual
calendar was likewise dominated
by the rhythms of agriculture,
the rhythms of what you did
daily, sowing, reaping,
hoeing, harvest or it could be
pasturing, lambing, shearing, butchering
and all the things that you
did in the pasture world,
but those were the activities,
the kinds of things you did
and that's how you told
time, you told the seasons
according to what you had to
do when you needed to do them.
On top of that, there were
also and most people thought
about not just the tasks they
had to do or the seasons,
but they also thought greatly
about the Christian calendar,
the feast days, time was
marked by great feasts,
not feasts in the sense of a lot of food,
but celebrations of
saints, Saint Bartholomew,
you'll hear about, Saint Martin.
We only have left pretty
much Christmas and Easter
from those times, but
every week had, every day
had a saint associated
with it and we'll see,
that's how they told time.
So work, life, feast days,
that's what structured
people's memory, that's how
they came to locate themselves
in time, historical time if you will,
so I want to illustrate
that by some quotes
which we don't, one of the
problems of doing preindustrial
work is that the people
didn't write anything,
they didn't leave diaries,
they didn't write letters
so we have to kind of
triangulate and get at them
from other ways what
they were thinking about,
what was going on in their minds
and one of the ways we get in their minds
was in England,
coming of age was a very important time.
You came of age if you were a man at 21,
a woman at 14 or 15.
And that was important
because at those ages
you could inherit land and
the king was very concerned
about that, who was gonna
inherit land that belonged to him
and so he had a whole system
set up called proof of age,
so if you think you're 21 years old,
the king would set up an
inquest, which was a jury,
and the local neighbors, 12
of them, would get together
and testify as to whether or not
you were really 12 years old
or you were 15 years
old or whatever it was
and so we have records of that that say,
these proof of ages, and you'll see that
they're not exactly what you think.
So I've got one and fortunately
there were two juries,
two inquests, that were
held three months apart,
one in October of 1303 and
one in January of 1305.
Let me just go through this very quickly.
First one was for John, son
and heir of Richard Tempest,
here's what they said,
William de Martin, age 60,
says that the said John
was born in Bracefield
on the day of Saint Bartholomew,
which is, you're right, 24th of August,
21 years ago, and he was
baptized in the baptistry
of the Church of Saint Michael
there and he recollects
the day and the year
because on the exaltation
of the feast of the Holy Cross following,
right, the 13th of September,
his son Patrick was born
who was 21 years old
at that feast last.
Robert Buck aged 41 agrees and recollects
because he was in school at Cliffrow
and on the morrow of the nativity
of Saint John the Baptist
25th of June, next before the said birth,
he was so badly beaten at
school that he left school
and from the day of that
beating, it was 21 years
on the same morrow last past.
What's missing from those accounts?
What would you normally
have if you were saying,
you think, 21 years ago, what's missing?
- A year.
- A year,
there's no calendar
year, no day of the week,
there are feast days, there's events,
that's the way you pattern your time,
you think about where you
were according to what
the feast day was and according
to what the (stammers)
whatever, so the next one, the next,
I lost the train of thought
there, that happens.
We'll see that in a second.
Emma, the wife of Richard
Fovell and the daughter
of Elias, this is the one
that's three months later,
this is the inquest, okay, so.
One of the interesting
things is this inquest
was held in the same town,
Skipped on a Pond Craven,
lovely town, you should visit it.
Emma was the daughter
of Elias de Ruleston.
Elias de Ruleston died in 1295.
And at the time of his death,
an inquest determined that
his heirs were his daughters
Emma aged three in 1295,
and her sister Cecily aged
three months who disappears.
So we fast forward nine years.
Nine and three is 12?
So we would expect the
jury to come out in 1304
and say 12 years old,
John de Keely, age 50,
says that the said Emma was
born at Fleshby on Sunday
for Saint Peter and
Cathedral, 22nd February,
15 years ago and was baptized
in the baptistry of the church
of Saint Andrew Cargrave and
this he recollects because
at the Feast of Saint Martin,
10th of November before that,
he leased a certain
land for a term of years
whereof at the Feast of
Saint Martin last 15 years
had elapsed and so the indenture,
he had a document shows,
so the document shows
that that's accurate,
but he says that she's
15, but clearly she's 12.
John was one of several men on both juries
and you can compare their
testimony, remember Robert Buck,
the guy who was beaten so badly?
Well, at the time, he
gave the first testimony,
he was 41, when he came
back in January, he's 38.
(audience laughs)
He recalled in October,
John's age, a few months later
in January, he agrees that
Emma is 15 and he recollects
that because Adam Buck, his
father, died 12 years ago
at the Feast of Ascension,
next, and the said Emma
was then three years old
and he was in the church
the day she was baptized.
More interesting is the
testimony of Elias de Stretton,
aged 70 in the first inquest, this I love,
having just turned 70, in
the second inquest, he's 60.
(audience laughs)
In the first he agreed
that John was 21 years old
because he recollected
that his wife Annabelle
died at the Feast of Saint
Martin, 10th of November,
after John's birth 21 years
ago, he's been a grieving
widower for 21 years.
In the second January,
he agreed that Emma was 15
years old because he recollected
that his wife Annabelle died
12 years ago at Christmas
last and on Sunday before the
Feast of Saint Peter Cathedral
following, the said Emma
was three years of age.
Now Elias was actually in the jury in 1295
that testified that she was
three years old in 1295,
but he says no, she's 15 years old,
so the point here is that this
is kind of a little window
you can have onto the way
in which people thought.
We all look at our watches,
we look at our time
and gradually as these
jurors were talking,
time was changing, they
were establishing work bells
in cities to get cloth
workers to work and appear
on time and when they
could take meals and when
they could go home, a
very small proportion
of the population, but
that's the start of it.
From work bells you get clocks in towns
and clocks tell the workers in the towns,
the cloth workers, the leather workers,
the beer makers, the beer brewers,
and all of those people when they can work
and when they can leave
work, when they can eat
and when they can stop
eating, then you start getting
clocks in homes and clocks in shops,
then those clocks get
transported to your wrists
or your pocket, actually,
first, you carry a clock
in your pocket and those
things tell you what time it is
but they also tell you what
your work is supposed to do
and it's the work that regulates the time,
it's the work that regulates
your life so that you think
not in terms of oh, this
task is gonna take so long,
it says I have so much
time to do this task
and suddenly time becomes a commodity.
You can save time, you can spend time,
you can waste time, that
wouldn't have made any sense
to Elias de Stretton or
any of his colleagues
at that time, the
apotheosis of this, I think,
is the FitBit, not only
does it calibrate minutes,
seconds, miniseconds, it
also calibrates heartbeats,
sleeping rhythms, brain waves,
so there's no part of your life
which is without regulation
and without the discipline
of time, it's that discipline
of time that's taken
centuries to impose,
those medieval villagers
resisted and resisted and resisted
and the history of
industrialization in the West
and in Europe is the history
not only of the imposition
of time but the resistance
of time, thank you.
(audience applauds)
- So I think we have a
PowerPoint presentation
and while that's happening
I want to thank Dean Steele,
Marks, Anna Marie Burke,
and others for inviting me
to be a part of this conversation.
So I'm gonna talk about
time in premodern Islam.
Premodern Muslims, it's fair
to say, were obsessively
and deeply engaged with time.
So you might find a philosopher
in 11th century Baghdad
who thought about the
relationship between God
and eternity, you might have a
11th or 12th century Persian
scientist and inventor
who spent lots of his,
who spent a lot of time
designing and building the best clocks
and astrolabes of his era.
And a 13th century
Anatolian mystic who tried
through his meditations to
transcend time altogether.
So in all of these sort of
deep engagements with time,
with defining it, with
pondering its philosophical
implications, with measuring it,
you see sort of engagement
across a range of disciplines
in Islamic studies, so to
talk in any serious way
about time in Islam is to
engage with art, art history,
history of science, Koranic studies,
philosophy, theology,
and the list goes on.
So what I'm gonna do
today is confine myself
to four areas, I'm gonna
highlight intersections
in terms of the study of the Koran,
cosmology, some cosmology,
history of science,
philosophy and mysticism,
so that's quite a lot for
the little time that I have
but I'll see what I can do.
Islam as some of you know was
born in 7th century Arabia.
It's a area that's
populated by pagans, Jews,
Zoroastrians, and Christians.
And to differentiate
itself in this environment,
Islam thoroughly and
radically redefined time.
For preislamic Arabs,
time and the Arabic word
or an Arabic word for
time, I should say, is
(speaks foreign language),
for preislamic Arabs,
(speaks foreign language) was
a cosmic force of its own.
It controlled what we
might say is transient
earthly happiness, it
ushered an inevitable death,
and we see an allusion
to this kind of view
in a Koranic verse that says,
they say there is nothing
but the life of this
world, we die and we live
and nothing destroys us but time.
So in contrast to this,
Islam imposed or asserted
a theocentric worldview,
a view that there was
a monotheistic omnipotent
God who was the ultimate
cause of all aspects of his creation
and that is referenced in the second
report that I have there, it's attributed
to the prophet Muhammad,
in addition to this
theocentric view or
alongside it, I should say,
there is this notion of an afterlife,
so Scott Waugh alluded
to it a little while ago,
but essentially what Islam does
is extend the time horizon,
if you will, of a believer to just
this is not, it's not just
the life of this world,
but there is an afterlife
to follow and Islam also
preached the idea that faith
and actions were ultimately
determinants of one's
destiny in the hereafter
and not just the passage
of time that would control
one's happiness or sorrow.
Now alongside what I call a
cosmological reconfiguration,
or as part of it, Islam
introduced a new calendar.
Most of the communities of that time
adhered to what we might
call a loony solar calendar,
right, a lunar or solar calendar
that was roughly calibrated
to the seasons, so I
mean, for us, in the north
we follow a solar calendar,
for us in the northern hemisphere,
January is always a winter month,
it was when I was young, it is now
and it will be when I am very, very old.
Islam instituted a lunar calendar,
and it's roughly 11 days
shorter than the solar calendar.
And what that means,
essentially, is that the calendar
is completely detached or
unmoored from the seasons
so let's take the example of Ramadan.
The holy month of fasting in Islam,
when Muslims fast from sunup to sundown.
In my youth, Ramadan was in the fall,
right, when the days
are shorter so the time
that you have to fast is a lot shorter
and now that I am 20, (laughs)
(audience laughs)
I won't say how old I am,
Ramadan is in the summer months
when the days are a lot longer and so
Muslims might fast something
like 16 hours, 17 hours
of the day, in addition to
this calendrical innovation
or change,
there were a whole host
of new rituals that were
associated with the
religion, so one of them
is the five daily prayers,
which were set at,
which are recited at set times of the day,
and they are also recited with a believer
facing the Kaaba, which
is in the city of Mecca
in Saudi Arabia, the
sacred center of Islam
and the introduction
of all of these rituals
was against the backdrop of
tremendous Muslim expansion,
from the 8th to the 16th
century, the Muslim world
expanded or grew out of its
boundaries in Central Arabia.
In the West, it went all the way to Spain,
in the east, to the borders of
China and so this historical
moment or these eras,
let's say, were accompanied
by tremendous advances in
sciences and technology,
the need to navigate across
this incredible expanse of land
and then for a believer,
wherever they were, to have
to figure what the time
of prayer is, when it is,
and how you figure out
where Mecca was or is, resulted
in sort of different types
of advances in astronomy
and you heard last week
that astronomy in the
premodern period was the queen
of sciences, so from about
the ninth to the 16th century,
Muslims were actually leaders
in the area of astronomy.
There are incredible astrolabes and clocks
that were invented in this
time that just testify to
the Muslim preoccupation with
astronomy, with technological
advancement and also with
absorbing a whole host of
cultural influences as Islam expanded.
One of these people was the polymath
Al Jezari Ibn al Razzaz,
Al Jezari, who wrote this marvelous book
that has been recently
translated from Arabic
into English, the Book
of Knowledge of Ingenious
Mechanical Devices, and
there are sketches in there
and plans for all sorts
of incredible devices,
that employed technologies that were
really advanced for that
time, in the 13th century,
12th and 13th century and
one of these ingenious
mechanical devices was this
awesome elephant clock.
It's also called the water
castle clock and it has been
reconstructed in a mall in
Abu Dhabi, in all places,
so if you're ever there,
you can go see how it works.
But you can see from the
clock that it incorporates
a number of artistic
influences from across
the Muslim world, there's
allusions to East Asian art,
and other geographic
regions of the Muslim world
and I have this very short
video because I am not
an engineer or a scientist,
I do Islamic studies
and history, I wouldn't
be able to describe to you
how this clock works if
I tried so this video
will do it for you, if
you can show the video,
I don't know if I have
to press something, or.
- [Narrator] This elaborate
clock has a display
at the top showing the number
of equal hours since sunrise
and marks every half hour
with a wonderful display.
It measures the passing
of time using a bowl
which floats on a water tank
hidden inside the elephant's
belly, the bowl slowly fills with water
from a hole in its bottom
and sinks every half hour.
When the bowl sinks, it
tugs a series of pullies
and mechanisms connected
to the top of the clock.
At the top of the clock, it
tilts a channel of balls,
causing one ball to be
released, this causes
the bird on the top to spin
and causes the hour indicator
to advance, the ball
travels through the clock,
falling from a falcon's
beak into a tilting serpent.
It causes a cymbal to sound
and makes the elephant driver
beat his drum and the
body of the elephant.
As the ball falls out
of the elephant's mouth,
the floating bowl is pulled back up
and starts filling with water again
for the next half hour.
- So very impressive, right?
I mean, and there were
other clocks like this.
Across the Muslim world,
actually, and you can get
a sense of how these were
not just mechanical devices
meant to tell time, they
were the celebration
of a cosmopolitan global
culture, they had an obsession
with precision, with
technological advancement
and with incorporating all
kinds of artistic influences.
Now in addition to these what I would say
are practical somewhat mundane
concerns of keeping time,
there were other Muslims who
grappled with more abstract
problems, 9th and 10th century, oh, no.
9th and 10th century Muslims
engaged with the ideas
of Aristotle and other Greek
philosophers who maintained
that the world is eternal.
Now this idea actually doesn't sit
quite well, it's not really compatible
with the notion of creation of a cosmos
at a fixed moment in
time by a creator God.
Muslims at the time who engaged with
the Hellenic tradition
were really impressed
with the Hellenic tradition,
they considered Aristotle
to be actually somewhat
of a Muslim philosopher,
if you will, and they tried
to integrate his thought
into Muslim thought and
philosophers like Avicenna,
Ibn al Arabi, articulated
a whole host of questions
and analytical frameworks
for trying to reconcile
Greek and Islamic
philosophy and they asked
all sorts of questions, I've
listed a few of them here.
Like what is eternity,
did it exist before God,
did God create time, does
time exist separate from God?
As an aspect of his creation,
and obviously I am not
going to talk about those
philosophical discourses here,
but I just wanted to sort
of highlight that this area
that is time and the
philosophical tradition
and the Muslim philosophical tradition
is a wonderful way to
explore the shared histories
and interconnectedness of
Greek and Islamic philosophy.
And I will just say in brief
that one of the solutions
that Muslim philosophers
put forth was that time
was indeed an attribute
of God, a divine attribute
like mercy and reason, they
enumerated a whole host
of attributes that were divine attributes
and time became one of
them, so obviously for some
Muslim philosophers and
theologians in particular,
concepts and questions of
time were to be tackled
through intellectual or mental exertion.
For the last group that I'll talk about,
Muslim mystics, also known as Sufis,
they took an entirely different angle.
For Sufis, time was an
experiential challenge,
not an intellectual one,
through rituals that involved
music and dance, Sufis actually
tried to embody eternity
so I'll give a very
brief explanation here.
In Muslim thought, right,
the creation of Adam
and all of humankind after
him represents what we call
the moment of a primordial covenant
with God, it was a moment
when humanity attested to
or submitted to divine will
and was in perfect harmony
with it, right, so Sufis
through their rituals
tried to return to that
moment of perfect harmony
or union with the divine
and they do this through
a whole host of meditations,
some are just invocations
that are recited, some are dances,
and one of the most well
known of these Sufi groups
is that associated with Rumi,
the internationally acclaimed
Sufi poet and philosopher
and his brotherhood,
his following, is properly
called the Mevlevi brotherhood,
but is popularly known as
the whirling dervishes.
And so I want to very, very
quickly play 30 seconds
of this ritual by way of concluding
and it really doesn't
do justice to the ritual
which goes on for more than an hour
but I just want to give
you a sense of how music,
movement and meditative
focus come together
in this ritual, do I hit?
(Arabian music)
That's very, very short
and doesn't do it justice
but I hope that conveys
a little bit of how
through this ritual, this
meditation, Sufis aim
to transcend time and unify,
each individual attempts
to unify with the divine
so in kind of through
these broad brushstrokes
of time in the Koran, in
the history of science
and philosophy and
mysticism, I hope that I've
sort of conveyed that there
is no monolithic concept
of time in Islam, instead,
it's much more appropriate
to see time as something
of a canvas where Muslims
sort of contemplated and
explored across the sciences,
arts and humanities, thank you.
(audience applauds)
- Oh, yes.
Yes, I think so.
Okay.
(sighs)
For me, time
is me.
Time is as I move my hand.
Time is between us.
I am time.
We are time.
I think
I might need the lights a little bit down
because I think that it is
just too bright overall,
please, thank you.
Yeah, that's better.
All right, I'll read a little.
Many of us consider
ourselves to be storytellers.
Perhaps even mythmakers.
And we all know that origin
stories are powerful,
we need as humans to understand
who we are, where we come from.
And to place ourselves
in stories in histories,
and in time.
My story and interest
in the question of time
begins in Mexico City,
where I was born and raised
to parents educated as chemical engineers.
They instilled in me, that was funny?
(audience laughs)
Who did it?
That was very funny because I saw,
because yes, they're chemical engineers.
I heard it back here. (laughs)
No worries.
(audience laughs)
Because I find that funny and
they instilled in me the love of,
everything that I would
ask, they would answer it
with the tome of organic
and inorganic chemistry
but what was wonderful was
that they instilled in me
the love and the fascination
for the natural world.
And especially the nature
of matter, its cycles,
organization, all of its
composition, so in a sense,
they taught me to see matter in time.
I took this photograph in the late 1980s
with my first serious camera
and this is the jungles
in Guatemala, in the border with Mexico
in an archeological site called
(speaks foreign language).
And it is (speaks foreign
language) in Maya,
which means great gate and
my family loved going into
archeological digs, it was
the passion of my father,
so so many times I lived just
in the jungle for months,
listening to the cicadas,
listening to the howler monkeys
and just allowing time to be,
surrounded by this incredible
jungle.
But also at the same time,
my father would teach me
about the obsession of the
Maya with time in general
and specifically about the
calendars in astronomy.
How they used three separate
calendars and they were
connected in three cycles
because they were cyclical
calendars, how the Maya
calendar system was not just
a method to track various celestial cycles
but it was a complex
system used to establish
which of the many gods
were ruling at each moment
in their lives, the gods
were constantly creating,
controlling, renewing the
world and all of the beings
within it, so there was a
fluid cyclical map of creation,
a making and unmaking, a
making and unmaking, and making
and unmaking of all existence continually.
So that sense of time
was so instilled in me
that it kind of, the idea of linear time,
I've had such a hard
time entering my brain.
There was a time that I
literally asked my husband
what century we were in
because that does not matter,
it doesn't matter in
my everyday and so yes,
time is gonna be a problem
for me, I already can see it.
Anyway.
Composer Carl Hein Stockhausen said,
we are transistors in the literal sense,
people always think they are in the world,
but they never realize they are the world.
What Stockhausen means is
that there are no phenomena
in the natural world that
do not manifest as vibratory
or rhythmic phenomena,
these vibrations attack us,
they modulate us, and in the end become us
so we are time.
With some of these ideas in
mind, I created this series
of works called At Any Given Moment,
which they are captured
with a 16 millimeter camera,
film camera, so that I
can have a materiality
to the work, they are
captured slightly slower,
they are 60 frames per second.
And they are just of these
moments where I found
one element that was repeated
and repeated and repeated
but that the light and its modulation
created incredible complexity.
(low vibration noise)
This is called At Any
Given Moment, Fall One.
And like that I created six in the series.
They get exhibited at very
large scale, 22 feet by 19,
with it's very dark but it's
about one ton of lava rock
and gravel and sand in
front of it, and that again,
it is I feel that time, I
experience it in my body,
I need to then create work
that makes me be present
and have a full embodied experience.
I wrote here, I create
work that makes me feel
like I am in the very
instant of the present,
it is so easy to be in
the mind, it is so easy
to be anywhere else, everywhere else.
And so in this way I also
create a place of repose
of the soul, 20th century
philosopher Henry Bergson
has had a profound influence
in my life and work.
He believed that time was
neither a real phenomenon,
a real homogenous medium
nor a mental construct
but possesses what he
referred to as duration.
Duration in Bergson's view was creativity
and memory, as an essential
component of reality.
At the core, a lot of his
ideas were thinking in terms
of time rather than space,
the very instant of becoming
is the now, the moment of
action, of the creative act,
of change, of chance, of
intuition, he said that being
is in the past and the
present is pure becoming
so I explored this
through getting a camera
that was 65 years old, bollocks reflex,
that I cranked it with
my hand so I could have
this sense of the apparatus
being an extension of my body
and therefore I could
not control everything
and thus the possibility
of chance to happen.
The possibility of my being
able to through the film
perhaps stopping and
going, that I could have an
amorphous sense of the present.
So in a way, my camera and I
are becoming with each other, oh boy.
I told you, time is gonna be an issue.
It's gonna be an issue, right? (laughs)
So let me move to the next.
With this work, I'm then
pushing further this idea
of using the apparatus
as the 16 millimeter
because it's a thick material
presence that it has.
In a way, this work, and I'm
gonna show you this video.
(atmospheric music)
By using the 16 millimeter
camera, I tried to have you
perhaps begin to see
some of the oscillations
and be aware of its
materiality and so it also
evokes the idea of looking at looking
and so you can oscillate
in the present moment,
you will see that a lot of
my work, I use 16 millimeter,
and I'll move to the next.
And I'm literally not even
halfway, so I'm in trouble.
This work, I'm exploring
infinity, the idea that through
the fog, the space that surrounds
me, that sometimes I have
this line, I can just go
and feel like there is
something is pulling at
the edges of the universe
and so for me this is an
exploration through light
and void of that nothingness
and there's more photographs
of this and here, I consider
the journey as a medium
in itself and I have
produced large body of work,
just looking, going to
extreme and unfamiliar spaces.
This work is called
walking, I have learned
that by being in a place,
sometimes waiting 12 hours,
24 hours, for phenomena
to act differently,
to perhaps show me a moment of otherness,
I live in a place where I
can perceive more precisely,
and this project, I have
myself, I filmed myself
walking the earth, the
project's called actually
Walking the Earth, with this work,
I will end it when I die,
I will go everywhere I go
and I will film myself
crossing that horizon line.
I want to see myself,
perhaps, with a little cane
but just going and
experience my entire life
walking the horizon.
French philosopher Michel Surtout argued
that the practice of walking is analogous
to the speech act and
can also be understood
to create a kind of spacing
or syntax in relation to how
things are encountered, walking
and travel are described
as a form of enunciation
that carries the possibility
of breathing life,
introducing a temporal beat
to the narrative.
So artistic field work is
the closest to what I do
as an artist in that
I place myself in a situation
where I go into the field,
I go and experience the
elements, rather than being
in the studio and trying
to control everything,
I need to have that relationship
with the environment.
An artistic field work,
then, is where you have
the introduction of
different fields of study.
I could be collaborating with
a geologist, a glaciologist, scientists
that are exploring the
earth and then whatever
you bring back, it can be
in any kind of artifact,
from a film, a video, a book, a poem.
And with that I have
created, I have traveled
to Svalbard, to the arctic region,
following the arctic tern,
and I'm gonna speak about
this project, Circumsolar,
which is now becoming with.
So if we were before
speaking about this becoming
in the moment of the present of Bergson,
this idea of becoming with so a little bit
of Donna Harroway's idea
of the world in together
with other species, with Circumsolar,
it's a longterm project
with a growing body
of artworks that emerge
from my profound love
of the arctic tern, its
unwavering determination
and the space it occupies in our earth
and our imagination.
Every year, the arctic
tern, a small seabird,
flies from the arctic to the
antarctic and back again,
making its migratory journey
the longest every recorded.
As a result, the arctic
tern experiences two
polar summers in a year, which
makes it the only creature
that lives the most daylight,
and that's a little bit,
you get a sense of its trajectory,
so this is a project that I,
it's a project that again, it might be one
that I will have my entire
life that I'll be doing
this project, this is, I
created a video that focuses on
the arctic tern's mating
and breeding season,
but the arctic tern is a
canary in the coal mine.
It is basically,
in 2012 we collaborated
with an ornithologist
and 90% of the chicks are
dying because of the way
in which the water is
warming up all around it.
And it was exhibited at
Globe that Mark Pally is here
and he was the creative
artistic director of the show.
And you can see it in my website,
it's called circumsolar migration one.
(atmospheric music)
And it focuses on the migration of humans,
of all creatures and that we must be
in movement and in time.
(atmospheric music)
And I think I'm just gonna close,
I'm gonna skip completely two projects.
And then this is an actual clock,
so this is a mural for metro
and it is 96 15 minute intervals
where, and it is going
to be installed in metro
in about a couple of months,
I just did a dry fit,
but it is a Day in Los
Angeles, it's 96 moments
of a day in Los Angeles,
it's built out of tile,
out of very small mosaic.
And that was only a few days
ago which was very exciting.
So as storytellers and
makers, we have an opportunity
to change the conversation,
to tell a story in self
and relation, but not
only at a planetary scale,
but within the history of the universe,
what American historian
David Christian calls
big history, in the 13.8 billion year
history of the universe
humans have only existed
in the world for 200 years.
As long as we do not have a
sense of this big history,
it will be very hard
to understand ourselves
as humans and that we
share urgent problems
that we need to work together with.
Gracias.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you.
Good evening, everyone.
All right.
My approach to time
as everyone else's is,
is extremely personal
and to really
give an eye into my
research, I have to give you
a little bit of my past and
how my life has impacted
the way that I look at
time so I'd like to start
by just talking about a few things.
Musical time changes
from culture to culture.
Seconds pass by in the same
manner throughout the world,
however, musical time is
reflective of cultural influences
and expressions, so one
of the things I wanted
to talk about first is
a couple of concerts
that occurred in New York
city about a month apart
when I was 29 years old, the
first was at Carnegie Hall
and it was with Winton
Marcellus, Bobby McPheron,
Anthony Davis, a professor at UCSD now,
a dear colleague of mine,
and a number of young
musical masters, it was called
the young lions concert.
And the music that was
played was modern jazz.
And so one of the points is that
the approach to time,
metrical time, a steady pulse,
was hyper precise and the
way that time was approached,
you could spread your emotions
over that hyper precision,
but one of the things that
had to occur is the fact
that everybody had to
agree where the time was.
You have to find that
commonality, you have to come
together, and you're taking
in not only what people
are playing technically,
but you're also intaking
what they are playing emotionally.
Okay, the second concert,
I was one of three soloists
at Lincoln Center with
the New York Philharmonic.
Walked out on the stage.
And amazing experience
and this concert was,
yeah, I said Lincoln Center.
The conductor gave his
downbeat and the orchestra
came in slightly behind the beat.
I said, oh, God.
(audience laughs)
Thank God I didn't have
to play that first chord,
but one thing that I knew
because classical music,
a lot of it the time, the way it unfolds,
the tempo, the pace of it is flexible
to fit the particular emotions that exist
within the composition so I had to play
in a very different way, I
also had to perceive time
in a different way than
the experience with
Winton Marcellus and Bobby McPheron.
And so on, so musicians, what do we do?
Composers, what do we do?
We learn different cultural approaches
and we bring them into
what it is that we do
and I think one other very quick point,
time is like a mystic.
You're chasing it.
You want to learn more.
You want to understand,
you want to become more intimate with time
because the more intimate with time,
the more profundity that can
exist in your compositions
and also your improvisations,
so with that being said,
what I would like to do
is could you play this video please?
We'll hear a few minutes of
it, I should let you know
this is an incredible Senegalese composer,
Doudou N'diyae Rose and
this is his ensemble
and one of the things that happens,
can you turn it up a little
bit, you got to feel it,
there you go, he's calling the ensemble,
they're getting up,
he's letting them know,
he doesn't say, okay, the
rehearsal's gonna begin,
he calls them with the sabar, on the side,
that's what we call a
toe post, that's a short
rhythmical phrase and all of
the music is built around that.
(drum music)
The tempo's gonna get a
little faster, just slightly.
(drum music)
I hated to stop it, oh.
(audience laughs)
But you can find it's online,
it's Doudou, D-O-U-D-O-U,
N, apostrophe, D-I-Y-A-E Rose,
and it's called the rose rhythm.
Did you hear a lot of
rhythms stacked on top
of one another?
We call those polyrhythms,
guess what's really important.
The rhythms speak to one another,
this communication is so essential,
it's such a key part of African music
where you have multiple
rhythms that are speaking
to one another and they're all stacked up
and they're in communion with one another.
So let's look at this, when
I think about time in music,
I think about it primarily in three ways,
on the level of the individual,
you can get a wide range of
the most profound aspects
of the human condition
communicated by the way
you approach the beat,
we're gonna talk about that
with Billie Holiday in a second,
on the communal level,
you know, it brings groups
of people together,
that's what you just saw
in that ensemble, they have
agreed upon the pulse, right?
Otherwise, you stack all
of the rhythms on top
of one another and it's like,
it's moving all over the place.
It's not working, you know?
And finally, I perceive it
as a continuous universal
calibration that allows us to connect
every aspect of creation,
no matter how close or far,
from micro to macro and infinity.
What I'm trying to say there
is I'm composing pieces now
that are images from the Hubble telescope,
they're giving me the form.
And if we think back to the
beginning of the 20th century,
Claude Debussy was buying
Japanese woodcuts in Paris
because he was so
intrigued with those images
and he figured out a
way to take those images
and move those images and
put them in his sound world
where you could hear Japan
in his orchestral works,
in his piano music,
isn't that fascinating?
Now 120 years later,
I can look at images
of the Hubble telescope
and compose.
It always pushes me to new territory
that I've never discovered before.
I'm finding new harmonies, new rhythms,
new ways of approaching
form and then I think
of the rhythm of the
image and the distance.
Okay?
How long does that image,
how much time passes
before that image gets to telescope
and we can then download it and see it
and receive these
amazing, powerful lessons?
Now I have to go to Duke
Ellington because jazz
is a huge part of who
I am, even though now
almost all of my music
is completely notated,
written for classical musicians,
but what I'm trying to do
in my research is taking
the time of the improviser,
the time of the African
and the time of people
from all over the world
that I've had the honor to perform with
and move that into a
fully notated context.
And what Ellington said
that was so powerful,
he says,
it is music, when he defines
jazz, with an African content
that comes out of an American environment
so it's all of the
cultures coming together
and mixing with that African root.
That's what I want to compose,
that's what I'm coming
out of, and communities
thrive on the ability
to interact within a
shared internal pulse.
How can this shared pulse be organized,
how does it function, how
does its function change
from one culture to another,
really intriguing questions
and we talked a little
bit about a lot of African
derived music has sort of
what they call a clave,
right, a key, so you have a rhythm like
(claps hands in beat)
Have you heard that before?
Okay.
It's called a (speaks
foreign language), the music
is structured around that,
it holds it together,
you can add all of the elements to
the basic rhythms that you're building on,
as Doudou N'diyae Rose went
to the side of the drum
to give the clave for that piece.
Then the other rhythms were
able to stack on top of it.
That's an amazing thing about this music.
So now, this is Doudou
N'Dyiae Rose right here,
a great master, one of the great composers
in the 20th century and the
beginning of the 21st century,
and he left us about, yeah,
he died in, I mean, 2015.
Now.
This is it right here.
(audience laughs)
This is the stuff.
Okay.
I gotta rush, so that means
that I'm going to have to
talk you through this very quickly.
What Billie Holiday did and
please go and listen to her,
we won't have time to play,
I'm gonna ask you to stand
up real quick, real quick.
I want you to lean forward.
Do you feel the energy like you
want to go forward like tat?
That's ahead of the beat.
(audience laughs)
You become anxious, you're
really excited about something.
I always use the image of two
people that love each other
so strongly and they
haven't seen each other
in three months and they're
running towards each other
in the airport, okay, that's a good one.
On the beat, you go to concerts, let's say
you're going to a hiphop
concert, a funk concert
and you see the heads
all moving to the tempo,
everybody's bodies moving,
all the students know
what I'm talking about, right,
that gives you a sense of
community, you all come together,
you want to be one.
You know, and that's really important.
Now I want you to just lean back slightly.
Sadness.
Tragedy.
pain, sorrow.
Billie Holiday would
start a phrase like this
and by the time she got
to the end of one phrase,
she was like that.
And that had to do with her
incredible sophistication
and number crunching and
having this hyper sensitive
relationship to the beat
where she can really play
and toy with the emotions.
I wish I could play you some of my music,
but I'm out of time.
(audience groans)
- Please, let's play it, let's play it.
(audience applauds)
- Okay, I'll do it really
quickly, I feel like
I should play Billie Holiday.
I'll play you a little
bit of Amazing Grace.
Some pieces, I'm torn between
that and the Orion Nebula.
(audience laughs)
But I guess I'll go traditional.
This arrangement came when
the tragedy happened at
Emmanuel AME in Charleston.
And President Obama, the
president at that time,
sang Amazing Grace at the
funeral of Clementa Pinkly.
How many of you remember that moment?
A number of you do, I was
so moved by that moment
that I wrote an arrangement
for string orchestra
of Amazing Grace and we
recorded it and can you please
hit the audio?
And it's in time, but
it gives you the feeling
that it's not in time.
(string version of "Amazing Grace")
Okay, thank you.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you.
- Oh, thank you, thank you.
(audience applauds)
- Fantastic, each of you, thank you,
all four presentations,
just spectacular together
and with an idea that
with the time we have,
we're gonna open the
conversation to everybody
in the room in just a moment, I thought,
prior to doing that, if
there was anything that might
resonate across the presentations
as you listened to them
that you'd want to speak about first.
I think I'm incredibly
struck by which the extent
to which each of you
presented this idea of time
as a kind of experience, maybe
in the most extreme version
as you said with the Sufi and mystic idea
that time is a part of our
experience of the world
and each of you touch on this
in really interesting ways,
historical, personal, in
terms of it being a part
of a world to arrange,
I'm curious if there's
anything in the presentations
that you were thinking of
as someone else might have
been talking about their
own ideas or experiences.
- Yeah, I mean, I think
that one of the things
that really stood out of me of course
is that we are under
this time regime, now,
I mean, we are very much
disciplined by time.
We are told to live by
it, but it seems to me
that other cultural constructions of time
that we have heard about
here actually allow
in different ways much more
of that, a fuller experience
of time as it were.
Through music or photography
or the mystical experience
where you can actually be in the moment
in ways that our time
regiment here doesn't allow us
to be in the moment so
all of these presentations
really help me think about
those cultural constructions
of time.
- And for me, for
example, it was incredible
how we can be talking
about time but the moment
that we actually feel
it, is like, the moment
that you started playing
the piece, not only
I was very aware of
what you became, right,
because you suddenly was like, it was like
you were inhabited by the
time that we're talking about
and I entered into a different place,
it's as if there is only
a very limited part of us
that exists when we are
speaking about something
and then we become something
so different when we allow
ourselves to actually experience it fully
with our entire body and
then we are in that present
and then we become and then we're creative
so I think that that was so,
so clear that I felt that.
- One thing I really learned
is that from everyone's
presentation is that we
can step out of the time
that we feel constricted to.
And live in other ways, I think
in everyone's presentation
and sometimes it's
connected to God, you know,
as you were speaking
about the feast and so on
and being gathered around
this and also thinking
about Rumi and
just how all of us,
a lot of times it connects
to God, the different ways
that we see God, and then
just this gift of realizing
that we have to get off
of this conveyor belt that's
just going too darn fast
right now, occasionally and
figure out another way to go
and how do we access
it, how do we get there,
from what I learned in
everyone's presentation,
is that there are a number
of avenues available
for that experience.
- Yep.
- Yeah, the number of different cultural
and historical frames
by which to understand
that experience, Scott, one
of the things you touched on
in your summary of it kind
of agrarian preindustrial
notion of time as a
lived experience is that
there was a kind of
unifying, what emerges as
a kind of unifying of
work routines and tasks
and behavior or social
life to a great degree
and one of the things that
that begs is questions
around the limits of that
as a kind of project,
the Fitbit being maybe the
current contemporary example
but the sort of broader
question that it opens up
about the ways in which we
can each not just individually
imagine ways to step out
of time but also maybe
in larger collective or social settings.
- Well, I think that it's important to,
in that respect, I would look
at the sort of university
and if you think about
the university, actually,
it has different time
regimens and there is
a kind of factory time which
staff and administration
experience, which is governed by the clock
and governed by very strict time.
Then there is student time,
which, whether you like
it or not is kind of
premodern, you do the tasks,
you can go to class, you
don't have to go to class,
you don't do the, you
don't read each chapter
according to time, but you kind of do it
at the last minute at two AM.
So there's a kind of
rhythm that is dictated
by the work that you do
and then there's, I think,
what's most fascinating is
faculty time which is...
I've always felt that the
one thing that the university
has do above all,
its main mission is to
protect in our world,
the modern world, the time for reflection.
It's the most precious commodity,
and reflection, I think,
is a kind of timelessness
in our culture where there's a bubble
where you let your mind
go, you be in the moment
and I think we've seen
really superb examples
of what happens when
people reflect and are able
to use that reflection
to express something.
But that's not factory or industrial time,
it's not Fitbit time
or whatever it might be
and I think if you think about
what the use of the university is,
it encompasses all those things
and that's what, you know, I
think is especially valuable
and you've seen brilliant
examples of just what it is
that that use of time does.
I don't like the term use of time because
I don't think, these
people, you're using time,
you're using your reflection, so anyway,
that's random thoughts.
- Another really striking
convergence across
the presentations for me was the ways
in which you in different
moments touched on
a kind of infinite time,
what you thought of
as eternity or eternal time,
and I wonder to the extent of which that,
I'm curious about that as
an idea in your own lives
and how you see the work you're doing now
in the longer arc of a
career or a form of research
or an ongoing project and how
you've experimented with that
over the course of your careers.
(Asma laughs)
- I mean, it's interesting, for me,
I mean, I think for all
academics, we think about
our writing and our research,
our scholarly production
as something that will
enable us to connect
with an eternal, right,
your writings outlive you,
your works and that, your
compositions outlive you,
right, but I have to say
that that is something
that I only think about
when really pushed to it.
I mean, the moments in
which I actually think
about eternity is when I think
about Islamic philosophy,
for example, I mean, it really
is a very abstract notion
for me and that's why it
was interesting for me
to think about the Muslim
mystics and the ways in which
through a particular ritual,
I mean, there is this idea
that you can actually experience eternity,
I mean, you can experience time,
you can experience the
past through the present,
and a future moment of happiness
through this, through an
embodiment, through a ritual
so I found that interesting
but beyond that I have to say
university time, I am
very much in the moment,
what do I have to do next, right,
there's a time panel I have to go to
and then there's a reception,
so I think that's how
most of our days are lived. (laughs)
- I think that in a few projects, I have
looked for that specific idea of infinity,
like you see those photographs
and then the nothing further
happens video in which I am
really kind of meditating
on the idea of the sublime but
in terms of the disappearance
of oneself or that connection
of oneself with the earth
so it's truly the dissolution of
a sense of individuality
and becoming matter
and becoming more universal and I think
of, you know, when I
think of the universe,
when I think of (speaks foreign language),
this incredible understanding
that we have of everything,
there's the corners of
it, it's when I think
of that infinity but
it does not include me
as a human as much, right,
it includes it as thought
because immediately I
come back like a yoyo
and come back to extinction
and what we're doing
with the planet and that I
don't see us as living beings,
with that sense of, you know,
unlimited existence.
On the other hand, it
really puts me exactly at,
what was it that the
humans existed only in
what's the equivalent
of the last millimeter
of the last square of a toilet paper roll?
Right, we consider the
existence of the universe,
that little little little thing is us.
So when I think infinity,
I think more geologically
and universal, not necessarily
as existence as humans,
and so therefore I do feel
immediately, boom, our finality.
- First of all, even before I comment,
I want to say how moved
I was by your images.
The images of infinity
were just so touching,
I just want to stand over
here and start crying.
(audience laughs)
And from everyone, it's
just been a really beautiful
profound experience.
I have to say I'm thinking
about eternity daily
and the reason
is twofold.
My faith is my life.
And
it impacts everything that I try to do.
When I come to this institution
to give the best of what I
have, my faith informs me.
When I go home and I
have the time to compose,
it's an offering to God.
And I feel that when I'm
in that room, I'm visited.
And
it, the visitation informs the music.
The visitation guides the music,
it leads the music.
And I set texts from the Old Testament,
the New Testament, I've
sort of turned my back
on the commercial world
years ago, and this is the
only thing I want to do.
And I just came back from a
conference at the Vatican.
I was invited by the head
of culture for the Vatican
and the conference was amazing,
people from 36 countries
coming together to talk about music,
and God.
Words and God.
And you come back from
that experience and being
at Assisi, you know, where
Saint Francis is buried,
and I think about Mahalia Jackson,
the great gospel singer
who could have sang
any music that she wanted
to, including opera
and so many other forms,
but everything she did
was an offering to God, so
I figured I was so crazy
and so bad when I was young,
I've got to do better now.
(audience laughs)
- Wonderful, I think it's
time for us to open up
the conversation to everybody in the room,
if we can do that.
We've got a couple of
microphones in the room.
I see a question right
up here up front, yep,
if we can get a microphone over here.
- Oh, okay, hello, so I think you guys
all gave like a very marvelous,
like, summary of your own
idea of time which I was
really moved by each and every
single one of them, but I was wondering,
time is such a vast topic,
like, anyone could agree
that time is vast and they usually take,
like if you ask someone with
all of these 10 questions
that you ask, like what
is time, what is beauty,
what is space and everyone
kind of pauses for a second
and they don't know quite how to answer,
would you agree that
one of the reasons why
it's very difficult to, I
don't know, express or define
or give a very like clear
answer to what is time
is because we as humans
don't have enough time
to even begin to like start explaining
what we're trying to say
and how was it that you guys
managed to summarize all of these things,
because I noticed some
of you were like trying
to rush through and I could
tell you didn't want to
but how did you manage
to crunch it all into
like a small space of speaking time?
- Obviously, I failed.
(audience laughs)
It seems that mine went on and on.
Well.
I think that it's just
the moment that you know
that you're basically having
a glimpse at something,
I mean, really, even what we said,
it's a glimpse of
what someone can be doing
the rest of their life.
I mean, I think that for some
of us, our thinking of time
has really been all our lives
and so now it's more like
okay, let's kind of, like
a lick of a cat, like,
that's what you got because
that's very, very little,
but it's...
For me, it's like being
in, trying to figure out
what does it mean to me in this instant.
- Anyone else about the
panel on this question
about how did you do it,
how did you get it down
to 10 minutes?
- Well, look, I mean,
I don't have an answer
for how did I get it down to 10 minutes,
but just to continue on
something that we touched on
before, I have to confess
that when I first received
this invitation, the only
thing that came to my mind were
jokes about Pakistani standard
time and Middle Eastern
standard time.
(audience laughs)
That's like what you use when
you're always late, right?
- That is so funny.
- But.
I know, I thought what am
I gonna say for 10 minutes?
But it really was an
opportunity for me to explore
all of these
interdisciplinary connections,
some of which I was unaware
of, I was mostly aware
of time and Islamic
philosophy, but I thought
one of the things that I
want to do in this panel
is to show the interdisciplinary
nature of engagement
with time across a religious civilization
and I thought, what are some of the things
that I can pick that would
be appropriate for this type
of a setting and how
can I just get it down
to two minutes per thing, so yeah.
- [Moderator] Wonderful.
- I chose the three musical
examples sort of first
and then started thinking about it more,
did any of you have a chance
to listen to the musical
examples, a few of you did, great.
I also wanted to include
Japanese gagaku music
because there is a sense
of floating at times
about how the music unfolds.
And the deep meditation that
the music is based on in part
and just the profundity of the sound
and at times it's almost
like the sound is swirling
in the room and if you
get that kind of feeling,
you're going to go
somewhere else very quickly.
(audience laughs)
You know, and how that
happens all over the world
has really fascinated me
so then after thinking
of the three musical examples,
it was more trying to not
spread too wide.
And just try to keep it fairly
focused and I also failed.
(audience laughs)
- No you didn't.
- Not at all.
- It's hard, it's really hard.
- Yes please.
- Again, I really enjoyed
the talk and it reminded me
a lot about some of the
elements that came up
in last week's with
space and my question is
do you see time, especially
since your disciplines,
time in some ways, is
it the canvas on which
you do your work as a
musician, as a photographer,
as a filmmaker, as a
historian, or is time itself
a tangible thing or is it
just a relationship of ideas
and do you see it as
a very objective thing
or a subjective thing, where does it lie?
And also I just wanted to
chide you for not having
your astrophysicist here
because if you're going talk
about time, so just, that relationship,
do you see time as some
actual tangible thing?
- Yes.
- Yeah, sure.
- There's a great blues
line by Robert Johnson.
And it starts, I woke up this morning
and I saw the blues
walking down the street
just like a man, what a
blues, gimme your right hand.
So the rhythm of the lyric, you know,
he's giving you a tangible
image, he's taking the blues
and he's turning it into a
person and all of that happens
while he is singing with one
rhythm, playing rhythm guitar,
with another rhythm
and playing lead guitar
with another rhythm, so just think about
what you'd have to do.
To have your brain do all
of that at the same time.
You know?
And so it's tangible and it's also
abstract, both.
- Wonderful, let's carry on
with the, yes, right here.
Sorry, don't mean to be
in one area of the room,
we're gonna spread it
out a little bit, but.
- Hi, thank you all for speaking.
My question is directed
mostly to the two artists
on the panel and I was
just curious, the thing
that struck the most
about what everyone said
but specifically the two of you was time
or art as a way of
stepping outside of time
and the sort of constraining
element that our modern
conception of that has on our daily lives
and I was curious, though, that even,
we see art as a sort of
profession that exists
outside of that, but it does still exist
in a capitalistic art market,
that has a demand for
labor and trade and time
and so I'm curious about how you at, like,
in your practices, how
you guys deal with that,
if you have any strategies or advice?
- I mean, it's an interesting
thing in terms of,
it's almost like I want
to answer a combination
of how do I experience
time because so many times
in my life somebody has come and said,
well, what you do is
like, it's not real life,
it's just, and all I can think is well,
you make the life you want.
And so in terms of the
living or being, you know,
is time a real thing, is like
as I mentioned in my talk,
it's like I am time, so
it's as real as I can be
and I can be real sometimes
and I can be very unreal
at other times so it's so much about
where
what you want to do with your life,
how do you schedule it,
then you cannot say,
when I have time, I'm going to do art
or when I have time, no.
It is what it is, it's
like I cannot help it,
I have to be making it, otherwise it is
like there is no air inside
of me so you have to live it,
breathe it, on the other
hand, is there a time
where I can actually step
out and stick to a timeline
like for a talk, right, so
for me, I have the other
problem, is that can I actually
step to do certain things
that are very pragmatic and
that I really would be measured,
it's like no, it's all
fluidity and sometimes
even in paying a bill right
here and I'm making art
right here, and it's just,
I'm more like this thing
and (makes silly noises).
(audience laughs)
- I love it.
- That is, there isn't such a
thing as compartmentalization
when you are an artist, I think, yeah.
(audience applauds)
- It's about your self
discovery as an artist.
And really finding out who you are
and what you have to say
that differentiates you
from every other artist on
the planet and trying to be
as great as you possibly
can, so many people think
about the business of art and visual art.
It's such a big deal now with the people
that have made a lot of
money from the stock market
going and investing in art that becomes
very fashionable.
Then they run on to someone
else and someone else
so if you aim for the timeless,
you are free.
(audience applauds)
- That's beautiful, yes, yes, yes.
- Wonderful, over on this
side, I see a hand, yep.
- I'd like to say thank you all again
and to you, what role
does timelessness play
in the scheme of time?
- I'm sorry, was that?
- I think that's open
to anyone on the panel.
What role does timelessness
play in your own lives
or your own work?
- I mean, you just said it, it's freedom.
- It is freedom.
- That, I mean, it's...
- I mean, one thing that I
realized from this panel is
that musicians, artists,
people who live in the
creating realm in ways
different from what I do is
are those who really
experience time and probably
timelessness far more
fully that I have ever
had the blessing to do so because for me,
time is essentially, it's a clock,
it's something that ultimately
can be very oppressive
and so to think about
experiencing timelessness
as I think you both have is not something
that I have given much time
to, I have to say. (laughs)
- Well, probably,
I think that's probably not entirely true
because I think that one of the things is
time becomes oppressive in our society,
I mean, it goes back to the question of
the young woman asked,
it is constantly present,
you are constantly reminded of
it whether you like it or not
and you're constantly trying
to configure your life
against it or whatever it
is because of deadlines
or because of needs and so the project
of stepping out of time
becomes I think priceless
and I think that can happen
in many different ways.
It's living in the moment,
where there is no time,
where time is eternal, which
are perhaps synonymous,
or living in a state of
rhythm where you lose a sense
of not the, you're so immediate in timing
that you lose a sense
of the larger context
so I think that notion,
I think we all aspire
to stepping out of time,
of not being oppressed
and finding ways in which we can do that.
You can do it in reading,
you know, when you're really
studying about something,
you can lose where you are.
I mean, I can go into an
archive and spend a day there
and forget how, it's not dictated
by the hours I was there,
it's dictated by the project,
and it's that project
which is, I mean, it's boring
and tedious for everybody else
but for me it was fantastic, and
so I think that that's, I think we all,
and I think that's the modern
dilemma in a lot of ways
is trying to find that
way in which you're not
oppressed by time which time
is not dictating everything
you're doing and the more you can do that,
I think the better off
you are but it's singular.
It can be through music,
it can be through art,
it can be through
scholarship, it can be through
sitting in the park, I
don't know, but I think
that becomes a project
for all of us which is
to not become enslaved by time,
because it is the modern dilemma.
- And can I just add
to this because I think
that as we're thinking about
it, it just occurred to me
that for me, it is the
creative act, feels timeless,
intuition feels timeless and
it is, it comes in leaps,
it's not that you build
towards it, sometimes you can
create the conditions and not get there
and sometimes you're washing
dishes and you have that
moment of boom, almost
like a knowing and totality
or something that just feels,
ah, it's as if this opens up.
And so timeless, it has no measure,
it more is an intensity
and I do think that I feel
that that intensity can
happen at any moment.
Sometimes it just doesn't
happen in an artist's residency
of two months and
sometimes it really happens
when I am petting my cat,
so when does it happen,
when does that creative moment
happen, so that I would say
is the timeless for me.
- Up top in the middle here, there's, yep,
right here in the middle, sorry,
bringing a microphone over.
- My question follows
kind of along the lines of
the gentleman earlier
about the astrophysicist,
but an observation I have was
a lot of the presentations
kind of
saw time through kind of a
human perspective as a stage
or a measuring tool to how we
organize or measure our lives
or humanity, either our
personal interactions with
our lives or
how humanity organizes from
more the other side, again,
as art, the lady said,
humanity's just the very
end of the toilet paper roll
but as time being the
whole entity of eternity,
that's a separate perspective,
I wonder if you have
anything to comment on
the different types of time, like I said,
we've been focusing more on the human,
how do we use it, how do we organize it,
in the greater realm, how
might that be looked at?
- I can answer a little bit.
I have, and I think that it's interesting
because so much of my work is about time,
so I have portraits of
mountains, for example,
and I just set the camera
and sometimes it's like
48 hours of a portrait of a mountain
and so I think that to
me maybe that is still is
my point of view, and it's my eye
but I am looking at more geological time
or maybe atmospheric time, really, because
nothing moved of the
mountain, but (laughs)
the clouds did move.
The bird, right, when I'm
looking at the arctic tern,
a lot of the times it is
for me is animal time,
I am actually trying to world with it
and I'm camping with the bird, and I am,
in order for me to film
it with the bollocks,
I have to learn the
pattern because once I set
the shutter speed, I cannot see anything,
so I'm learning when is
it going to actually dive
to go eat, so I think
that our times combine.
And so for me I think that if anything,
it's less my time and more its time,
whatever I'm filming,
whatever I'm documenting,
even the time of the
apparatus, I'm more interested
in how the machine is
going to actually (clicks)
do its thing.
So I try to
let go of my own time
and there's times that
I've cried of exhaustion
because there is nothing is happening,
nothing further happens,
and I'm like (sobs)
I'm running out of film, I can't do this,
so it is something that I
am a slave of this time,
other time, and I enjoy
that, being taken away
and ripped out of my
humanity, if I could say.
- I think I'm inspired by
women and men who have been
looking at eternity, maybe
through a combination
of art and science, better guide ways
to begin to take in the
possibilities of eternity.
And I can think of a number of artists,
whether they're in music
or visual art, literature,
but I really believe that
the integration of the sciences
with art is going to be
a very important
evolution for humanity,
just how it comes together
in new ways to embrace
the possibilities that exist of eternity.
There's so much more
that we have to learn.
We are such babes.
You know, and particularly
when we begin to view
eternity, it's like if I had my druthers,
there's a huge part of
me that would have loved
to have been an astrophysicist,
but there weren't many
in my neighborhood.
(audience laughs)
But...
I just...
Because that's an important part,
it's like I have to study physics more,
to do the next projects
that I really want to do
and it's finding the time
to approach that eternity
and I really appreciate
you bringing that up
because it's so important for you and I.
- Thank you, and in that,
we're coming to the end
of our time, I thought
maybe we could close,
to see if any of you have
any closing statements,
anything you'd like to
say that kind of tries to
draw a thread between a few
of the points up to now,
Asma, you were about to say something.
- Actually, I was going to
just respond to that question,
if I can do that instead
of a closing statement,
that would be good,
I mean, I think that not just
Islam but world religions
do a great job of this, of unsettling
human beings from their current perception
and rigidness in time and
having them think about
eternity and I mean, if
you look in the Koran,
there are, and in Islamic literature,
there are 25, 30 different words for time,
measuring it in different
ways and talking about
this idea of an eternity and
talking about what a day is,
you know, in the eyes of God
and sort of the Old Testament
and the New Testament and the Koran,
the lifespans of certain
prophets, like what Moses lived,
what, 900 years, I mean, I don't remember,
but there's just this, I think
all of the world's religions
constantly try to unsettle
sort of regular human
perceptions of time and have
us think about eternity,
pre eternity and then
extend our time horizons
to an afterlife.
- Thank you, Scott, Rebecca,
either of you, closing?
- [Scott] Go ahead, you will
have something more interesting
to say.
- No, no, no.
But I have said so many
things, I will say it,
but maybe after you. (laughs)
All right, so then I'll go.
I have collaborated with
geologists and with glaciologists,
ornithologists, but it is something that
for me, I agree, like one of my very,
when I was young, when I
was about, I don't know,
14 or so, I went to NASA,
and I wanted, I was sure
I was going to be an astronaut.
And because I continued to
have that desire of expansion
and just understanding
this sense of the universe
extent and duration, not just the extent.
So I know that I've been studying
like (speaks foreign language)
again, just the universe itself,
and it's just so amazing,
the concept, when I feel
that I am kind of getting
a sense of getting a little
bit lost, I just have that
image of that universe and
the way in which we are trying
to map that infinity
and it is so inspiring
so for me it is like the
collaboration with science again,
it inspires me, so much, so much
and I feel that that's where
I feel the...
Both, and our relationship
to animals, for example,
for me the post human, the
idea of that I do believe
that our humanity's gonna
come from my relationship
with wild animals, so that is another way
of entering another universe,
so it's in one way very far
and on the other hand is
like what is our humanity,
'cause we have lost that
connection, we're very isolated.
- Francisco Toledo.
- Si, claro.
(speaks foreign language)
- Scott, last words?
(audience laughs)
- Well, I guess what I
was trying to say was that
the way we live today,
where our conception of time
is a construct, and it's a
construct that's been imposed
on us through a lot, many, many years,
knowing that doesn't allow
us to deconstruct it,
but knowing it does
should free us to do projects
which either work against
that construct or allow us
to escape that construct
in different ways, and
I think that it's vital
that we understand that we,
that our notion of modernity
as it's been fashioned
through industry and factories
and through a variety of other things,
through stopwatches and
watches and trying to tell
better time is a regime
which we brought on ourselves
as humans, and that
we're all as victims of
it, too busy, too harried,
too stressed and we need
to understand that it is
a regime we've brought on ourselves,
it's not the regime of arctic terns,
it's not the regime of rhythms,
it's not the regime of
even the mechanical clocks
of elephants, so I think it's
important to understand that
and understand what it is
and understand the ways
we get out of it into the moment.
- Wonderful, thank you,
and everybody in the room,
please join me in thanking our guests
(audience applauds)
for their time.
By my back of envelope calculations,
if there's 300 of us in the room,
we've just spent 600 hours together.
The most delightful 600 hours
I think of the week for me,
most certainly, join us next
week for what is beauty?
Look forward to seeing you all then.
- Wonderful, I can't wait.
(audience applauds)